هكذا بدت مظاهر العصيان المدني هنا في حي
العيساويه واحياء اخرى في القدس الشرقي
اضراب تجاري واغلاق شوارع ومواجهات بين كر
وفر بين الشبان والقوات الاسرائيليه التي
انتشرت بكثافه حاولوا
بالرصاص والغاز بالمطاط كل الطرق يلغوا
هذا العصيان ولكن استمر لهذه الشعر خطوه
الاحتجاج التي امتدت الى معظم احياء القدس
الشرقيه جاءت احتجاجا على ما يصفه الناس
هنا بحمله انتقام وتنكيل وتضييق يقودها
وزير الامن القومي الاسرائيلي المتشدد بنج
فير متمثله بهدم المنازل وتحرير مخالفات
سير وملاحقات ضريبيه الى جانب الاعتقالات
والمداهمات ان وحدت جهود محطاتهم بامل ان
شاء الله تكون رساله برضو للقياده
الفلسطينيه المجتمع الدولي انه ينظر بعين
الاعتبار للاهداف اللي بتصير زيكا على
الشعب الفلسطيني
ات الفرديه في القدس ما ينذر بما هو اخطر
حيث حذر المفتش العام للشرطه يعكف شوبتاي
ان هذه الاجراءات ستؤدي الى غليان وتفجير
للاوضاع
تخوف اسرائيلي من ان يكون العصيان المدني
هذا بمثابه شعله لمواجهه قد تجر الضفه
الغربيه الى تصعيد اكبر واشعال الاوضاع
الامنيه في ظل اصرار الحكومه الاسرائيليه
على استمرار النشاط الامني في القدس
الشرقي لا نقول غاصي من القدس الشرقيه
المحتله العربيه